even the tightest of ships will spring
leaks now and again and keeping a vessel
the size of Star Wars completely
watertight is near impossible even with
JJ Abrams back at the helm for episode 9
the forthcoming entry to the main space
saga isn't due to arrive until December
2019 but the rumors are already starting
to trickle through if you want to go
into episode 9 completely spoiler free
this is your cue to click away but if
you can't resist the urge to find out
what could possibly be in store for Ray
Finn and Poe let's take a look at what
we might already know about the next
journey to a galaxy far far away Ray's
real parentage speculation surrounding
Rey's parentage has swirled ever since
the force awakens came and went without
revealing the details of her bloodline
in the last Jedi kylo Ren told her that
her parents were just a pair of filthy
junk traders who had sold rey off for
drinking money but was he being honest
many suspect that he wasn't and a new
casting call has ignited the debate over
Ray's family once again
according to alleged leaks from that
hashtag show Abrams and casting director
Nina Gould are searching for a female
lead between the ages of 40 and 50 to
fill the role of Mara the name is an
obvious reference to Luke Skywalker's
expanded universe wife Mara Jade but the
name may also just be a placeholder once
Disney took the reins Mara was erased
out of continuity but the recent
novelization of the last Jedi revealed
that Luke actually had a wife back on
Tatooine the stars may seem to be
aligning on this Rimmer but will mara
jade turn out to be Ray's mother
according to his friend and colleague
Simon Pegg Abrams had something just
like this in mind when he made the force
awakens he told Josh Horowitz on the
happy sad confused podcast I know what
JJ kind of intended there was some talk
about you know a kind of relevant
lineage for her so perhaps episode 9
will give him a chance to circle back to
the still unanswered issue of Rey's
origins Return of the Hutts
reddit is filled with supposed leaks
about Star Wars which means the genuine
ones can sometimes get lost in the noise
the user named 4-lom is to be believed
through a post tagged probable BS they
may have an inside track on episode 9
rumors via a colleague doing some visual
effects work on the picture which has
led to some pretty exciting rumors being
shared if what this person says is true
then the notorious Hutt cartel is set to
make a return to play an important role
in the film as unlikely allies of the
resistance according to the source
it'll be Jabba's son who steps up to
take over his dad's shady business in
the film fans may recognize righta as
the baby Hutt who was kidnapped as part
of a plot to discredit the Jedi Order
during the Clone Wars as described by
this redditor The Rose Finn and Poe
triad will be revisited in episode 9 as
they cross paths with the Hutt cartel
for a big dinner scene with a musical
number in play the same leak also
suggests we may see Benicio Del Toro's
return as the double-crossing DJ by way
of this same grouping DJ will allegedly
be involved with the Hutt's and Finn and
Rose will be understandably furious with
him but Poe will apparently see him as a
quote necessary evil and he may even
join the squad after a raid by the first
order judging by the recent interviews
that del Toro has given regarding the
character it seems pretty clear that
he's ready to step back into DJ's boots
so perhaps the next film will give him a
chance to redeem himself after all a
time jump another editor called puzzles
claims to be privy to an early
storyboard that was being used back when
Colin Trevorrow was still attached as
director and said there will be a
five-year time jump between the last
Jedi and episode 9 in that time kylo Ren
will have fooled most of the galaxy into
thinking he's a benevolent ruler
meanwhile the resistance will have lost
popularity even within its own ranks as
people questioned why they should be
fighting anymore it's worth noting that
John boyega has hinted that there will
be at least some kind of leap forward in
time for episode 9 when he mentioned in
a recent interview I can't wait to start
shooting the next and final leg of the
franchise the first step is growing out
my hair so you can wait for the trailer
to see why the storyboard also
apparently goes into great detail about
a secret ocean covered planet that the
first-order uses a giant war factory
underneath its oceans there supposedly a
colossal workshop manned by the enslaved
peoples of countless other planets and
to get there this rumor suggests Finn
ray and Poe will have to enlist the help
of an alien prodigy who knows her way
around the Unknown Regions once they
find the place they'll also reportedly
try to liberate the captives below who
work in the ancient manufacturing
station may power as for how the heroes
discover the location of this top-secret
planet in the first place
the rumor says there is a surprising
mole in the first order apparently
domhnall gleeson x' snivelling general
Hux will resort to feeding information
to the rebellion as part of his efforts
to undermine kylo ren's rule his brief
attempt at putting himself forward as
supreme leader in the last Jedi was
literally choked out of him by rent so
Huck's clearly doesn't like the new boss
it may not give up on his ambitions to
take control snoke's
second life when Colin Trevorrow parted
ways with Lucasfilm
over so-called creative differences
stories regarding the real nature of his
departure from episode 9 started to
circulate one rumor making the rounds
was that the director was fired after he
argued with the studio over the fate of
Luke Skywalker and Supreme Leader Snoke
both of whom he apparently wanted to use
in episode 9 if true well he obviously
lost that argument and his job to
Trevorrow called it a very acidic
situation when he later sat down with
Uproxx adding sometimes creative people
can't find a shared path through the
woods in what would be a cruel twist of
fate if all this is true it looks as
though true Burroughs replacement will
get to use those characters after all
according to Star Wars superfan Mike
zero
a more recent storyboard has been leaked
and it apparently features Snoke with a
shadowy figure that looks like kylo Ren
there's also a rumor that Lucasfilm may
cast Edie Harris and digitally de-age
him so he can play a younger version of
snow perhaps through the force vision
flashbacks that Abrams introduced in the
force awakens this does sound like an
interesting idea but if Andy Serkis has
anything to do with it
we'll also get to see the older
disfigured smoke again in Episode nine
the motion capture wizard has hinted
he'd love to return to the role
admitting that he'd be very happy to
extend snoke's life and he may be in
luck because the leaked working title of
the film might even hand it circus
coming back
according to Fanta tracks the working
title for episode nine is Trixie what
does this have to do with circus many
are seeing this as a nod to his
portrayal of Gollum and Peter Jackson's
Lord of the Rings films in which he used
the term Trixie regularly as leaks
rumors and spoilers go this one might
seem awfully thin but Lucasfilm has been
fairly Trixie themselves in the past so
it would be a mistake to ignore the
possibility back to Naboo last but not
least there are reports that JJ Abrams
might also be planning on returning to
the planet Naboo there were already
rumors that the birthplace of Luke and
Leia's mother Padme Amidala might be
where we'd see general Leia Organa laid
to rest but some concept art supposedly
seen by a french source featured the
planet's pristine beaches and coastlines
not a funeral
of course leia is still alive as of the
end of the last Jedi but given the sad
fact that Carrie Fisher passed away in
2016 most are assuming her character
will be retired with some dignity pretty
early on in episode 9 Lucasfilm already
confirmed that they will not be
rendering a digital version of Fisher
for the film so we shouldn't expect
another rogue one style resurrection
this doesn't mean that the Naboo story
is a false leak however Abrams has
previously stated that he wants to tie
all three trilogies together in some way
with this film and a return to Naboo
would be a nice link to the prequels
also Lucasfilm location scouts have
apparently been spotted in Spain which
has doubled as Naboo in the past of
course these are all just rumors for now
so it's hard to know for sure what's to
come but if any of these supposed leaks
do turn out to be true it sounds like
the force will certainly be with the
film as we follow our heroes on another
fascinating journey ahead
[Music]